all right what do what do you got big
piece of
paper we should probably audibly say
what we have out so the audio listeners
can keep up that's what I've been saying
uh uses astrology
unironically uses astrology
unironically
okay God I'm so glad I'm taken I would I
probably seem like the most unattractive
person right now you know what you want
Jerry that there's nothing wrong with
that want all right say what your answer
is on three 2 one red red red yeah we
can all okay look this is this is just a
dude answer I I think every single dude
watching this episode right now can
agree sorry ladies it's just like when
something goes wrong and then someone
tells me yeah it's just not a good month
for Leos and I'm like I'm like I will I
will kill you and then they'll be like
that is what a Leo would say I'm like I
will I cannot
express how much I hate that you think
that one in 12 people are exactly the
same and can be interpreted by the
movements of [__] science I just stop
belly laughing like that it's it's some
of the funniest pseudo science out there
and I really hope it doesn't stop CU it
never gets it's also just frustrating to
for me when I feel like it is okay to
admit that we just don't know things as
a as a population that we just don't
have it figured out and I hate that it
is trying to give some agency to give
people a a feeling that they know it but
I feel like knowing nothing is better
than knowing something completely
incorrect people are weird and there's
no Rhyme or you know reason to it
sometimes and you can't like you can't
pigeonhole them into like a specific
like trait or M or whatever not how it
works yeah I mean there's like different
levels of this cuz there are some people
that base their entire lives around want
to do it for yourself for fun but if you
stop bringing it into every into that my
life into it I'm I think the important
word here is uses astrology unironically
cuz I know plenty of people there just
like to have fun with it and that's
[__] fun I love using it ironically
cuz it pisses people off and it's so
funny seeing their reactions cuz it's
like that's how I react when some
someone says it un ironically and it's
really funny yeah I think uh if if you
if you use it and you're not like
pushing that [__] on me it's fine but um
I also don't want you I also get
concerned if like your life is going to
[__] and you're like well I guess it's
just cuz Mercury's in retrograde yeah
no what are you talking about yeah it's
it's like I think like the planet
doesn't give a [__] about your feelings
yeah for me like the like the male
equivalent to like astrology is just the
[__] like stock Bros and crypto Bros
who who are just like
yeah listen listen dudes we we've been
very harsh this is a very generally
female uh fale such horrible word you
know leaning towards more uh feministic
kind ofan experience yeah we could have
been like oh they trade Stars been like
[__] green bro it's so sick yeah I've
had a bad day Bitcoin wi down two points
you know I think that yeah we we we've
been we we have we have our own viic as
well that are equally as I think red
flaggy but yeah shout out to the dudes
who use astrology by the way no no you
are you are the minority and uh it's
hilarious keep please keep doing it just
let's uh let's not use it unironically
let's just keep it for fun like any kind
of like Po like personality
like that's that's what like kids who
are getting bullied at school she use to
retort okay well I don't why am I being
me Leo because that's that's the real
Leo energy you're giving me right now
you need to stall all right next one uh
uh having an obsession example Disney
adult just any Obsession it's okay yeah
we the Disney adult so an adult obsessed
with Disney is an example but just
having an obsession
well well okay how do we want to do this
I can we stick to just Disney please
being a Disney adult CU Obsession
everyone has an obsession yes of course
but we're talking about specific
obessions here let me rephrase then
green flag red flag Disney
adult I I don't know why I did this okay
I'll tell you what I just did by
accident um oh God okay so so the qu the
question now is is a Disney adult a red
flag is a Disney adult a red flag or
green flag for you as a part FL in The
Gallows if he answers this
wrong 3 two one red what what the [__]
is it actually a [__] Disney
adulty is not a Disney adult no she is
she's a Disney every goddamn Joey how
many times you're on objection I see
I'll pull up on Instagram right now was
she within Disney in the past week yeah
okay I rest my case but I will come here
to defend my girlfriend first of all she
only goes to Disney a couple of times a
year objection cop your honor which I
think is fine I know because that's the
days I avoid second of all she's not a
Disney fan she's a Kingdom Hearts fan
which automatically wor objection it's
worse you're H agree I will agree on
that but I think like my definition of a
Disney adult right and I've met some
actual Disney adults are people who like
say for example you live outside of the
States you go to California
right there's a Disneyland there perect
if you're in Disneyland every single
[__] day or multiple days in a row
that's a Disney adult I think where like
everything around your house is Disney
themed you only watch Disney movies you
like deep dive into like the Disney law
and there are lots of people like that
to me that's a red flag I think there's
nothing wrong with liking Disney there
is or like liking Disney movies I like a
lot of Disney movies and you know I
don't like Disneyland in general just
cuz I don't like amusement parks right
but I think liking Disney there is wrong
with a Disney adult is something on
another level okay what if okay okay but
Aki is like is not copi swear this is
the Charlie Day image of Joey like let
me explain to you why Aki is not a
Disney she's not a Disney adult listen
she would be offended if you called her
a Disney adult she could become one very
easily which is why I'm here to stop her
okay okay I'm showing her Classic Movies
you would be you would be unhappy with
if she went further down the Disney path
yeah and she knows
that you this honey you have to stop no
I straight up S to I'm like you can go
to Disneyland with your friends that's
fine just chill out a little
bit watch a couple of other mov warnings
boundaries have I've said look I'm a
very straightforward person if I think
you're going to become a Disney adult I
will tell you um yeah I mean my
reasoning is that like I don't like
Disney I don't like what they do that's
fair uh I think that basing your whole
personality around their movies is a
rapid way to spend your life on this on
this time on this planet does not has a
lot of other likes and wants and you
know a lot of other obsessions Disney is
just one of them am I one to talk I play
League of Legends for seven years so I I
shouldn't that that would definitely be
a red flag um FL I just don't like how
Disney does what Disney does uh and I
think that people I hate how they do
business I hate it they're they're
they're are evil cor they're so evil
they so and they they they dominate they
they [__] people over but
I straight up also the new new movie
suck I'm just going to say it right now
all the movies suck live action remakes
that they keep pushing I'm not a fan can
we stop doing this not a single one of
their remakes have been good uh I think
they're terrible all all they've been
doing I hate Disney plus I Hate
Everything it stands for I think we have
too many subscriptions uh and I'm glad
that they lost the rights to the cricket
in India so they so they lost that
market yeah they did they had could you
imagine you wanted to watch cricket
ninja you got to [__] sign up to
Disney
plus um I I you're watching the Disney
Channel I just hate Disney I think that
F inning I I I don't know man they they
just feel like a bully as well as a
company oh yeah the fact that they
wouldn't let a guy famously have a
Spider-Man Tombstone for his his uh
young kid who died of a disease and they
they gave him a cease and deist to
remove the Spider-Man wait did they
actually yeah yeah that's [__] up um I
feel like they're just cruel and I don't
like Disney as a company and then I feel
like basing your whole personality off
of just a company is bizarre yeah that
true would you say the same thing about
Nintendo though 100% yeah Nintendo
adults are like a different breed
they're like the same kind of thing like
if you like like if you un ironically
like Kirby you should end your life you
should not be allowed to
vote Nintendo Bros and uh Disney
princesses
a lot in common you know let me okay let
me say one word maybe they should end up
with each other let me okay there is one
thing that youed flag or green flag
Nintendo with their their happy go-lucky
suing uh is is encroaching on like
Disney levels dude as a Nintendo fan
there I said it as a Nintendo fan I
think that's also [__] up and I
absolutely do not stand by that I think
you know the fact that they are
incredibly hypocritical with that [__]
as well you know like the fact that like
the Wii Virtual Console like retro games
later found out to all be emulated Yeah
well yeah they they and they straight up
re uploaded somebody's emulation of the
original Super Mario Brothers onto the
week Virtual Console which I think was
just absolutely hilarious so I think yes
as a company I think Nintendo has done
some really shitty things continues to
do some really shitty things I just
[__] love their games no the games
are great and that's that's the same I
don't I don't think a lot of Disney like
adults think that deeply about it I'm
sure even some of them are like aware of
the business practices but I think if
you're going to sign your life away and
your whole personality to a brand you
should at least be aware of the brand oh
for sure and I think Nintendo it's that
constant like you're like God damn it he
he's a dick but man he he's so fun to
have
around you know that's the vibe Nintendo
gives off yeah um that's the reason why
everyone their games are great my answer
is not that deep I was just like I've
just never liked Disney stuff so I'm
probably not going to Vibe with this
person if they're going to be a life
partner yeah a lot of a lot of people
also Bas the whole personality on Disney
are a little bit obnoxious sometimes too
but I also know some Disney adults who
are absolutely chill and very nice
people but I just personally no
absolutely and I think like again
there's nothing wrong with being a
Disney adult as long as you actually
have some like other things to [__]
talk about it Obsession should be in
moderation whether it be Disney whether
it be Nintendo whatever it might be and
uh if you really really like Disney but
you also like a lot of other things
which Ary does I don't think there's
anything wrong with it yeah I mean I
think it's hard to draw the line of
where that's not a Disney
adult L listen there is a reason why we
have the word Disney adult everyone
knows what that means because that
someone who only likes Disney there's no
there's no anime adult there's no JoJo
yeah but a wee we we know anime adults
no because it's a different vibe the
word Disney adult gives us a very
different feeling to the word
weeb yes Disney adult is I would always
consider very negative is it because
when you say the word wee you imagine
like a 12-year-old a wee you just
imagine like someone who's a casual
anime fan like when I he Disney adult I
think I picture the Karen cutting in
line just being like this is the perfect
route to the Disney theme park we have
to do this no that's just a Karen
who's yeah um I I mean I I guess we kind
of like narrowed down the wording of
this but I guess a lot of what we said
could be applied to anyone with like a
massive Obsession I guess the the the
general thing is that there more is well
known with Disney adults Disney they are
the loud minority
well I don't know about minority there's
a lot of them well in the grandest scale
some buying these the grandest scale of
the human race they are the minority all
right well let's do the next one